[Applause]
one question an amazing lineup of CEOs
Founders and experts this is marketing
for the now
[Music]
hey Gary
it is wonderful to see you Andrew how
are you I am good I am good happy
Passover thank you to everybody out
there
sounds like a lot of people are um also
heading off on some early Easter uh
vacations and things but hopefully
they're going to listen to this because
we're going to talk about all the things
that you need to know about AI it's
going to be a good one I'm excited not
only about the topic but I'm excited to
have Avery join you in this conversation
let's bring her up
Avery Avery acanini our president of
vayner3 welcome welcome Avery
thank you guys so much for having me
thank you Andre always for putting these
on and thank you everyone for tuning in
to marketing for the now
um we're excited to do a little bit of a
different format this time we have a
couple of brand guests and we're also
going to do a couple of demos
um but before we get into all that fun
Gary wanted to start by asking you some
questions of sort of what's on your mind
with AI you know internally we've been
talking about this since the summer when
mid-journey and then subsequently
evolving two sort of caught our eyes
um and then Chachi PT happened and 100
million users also caught on to that
um so how big of a deal is generative AI
for brand builders and infra marketers
I mean it it's and I think we've seen
the you know headlines
um over the last 30 45 days it's so big
that you have some of the biggest names
in technology history saying you're like
hey should we contemplate taking a
collective human pause for six months
and really try to understand this
um it is a profound technology you know
I think back to search really hitting
the scene the internet and then search
engines and it was like wow this is like
a big deal for like human information
capacity efficiency like literally I
don't have to drive 32 minutes or if I
live in a rural area or 15 minutes a
city or five minutes to the library find
the encyclopedia or the book or the
reference it it was just like wow things
that used to take even 10 minutes in
your own home to go downstairs get the
encyclopedia fight like 10 minutes
became 10 seconds with search and so
much happened AI is like a whole
different like I I bring up search
because it's an easy quick comp but it
the multiplier on artificial
intelligence is profound it gets smarter
it's not stagnant
um and what it's going to mean to
creative I was talking to a musician the
other day and he was like Gary how
should I think about this I was like
well do you understand that you'll be
able to like
probably get very good Insight on what
you should title your song like that the
machine learning is going to get so
strong that hey what you know if I want
this to happen what should i title this
song or testing hooks or extracting
hooks I mean it just gets so wild it's
really difficult Avery to completely
comprehend the profound nature of what
it can do and you know obviously I think
the big elephant in the room is
trademark and and copyright you know I
hear that bubbling up a little bit
behind the scenes right now
um but this is very very very
substantial technology and and I really
don't see anyone on Earth not being
affected by it
um especially because you really clearly
can see already with the chat EBT apis
like Food Services like SEMA others like
already starting to play with it and so
very quickly you're like oh right like
you know Alexa and Google Home and these
things they're going to get stronger
because the race is on with the biggest
tech companies and then oh right all
these consumer apps are going to start
layering AI into their environment so we
use them every day
so
yeah I think it's a it's a big big deal
and um so big that I think we're
drinking from the fire hose but being
thoughtful on how we're going to execute
against it
there are some practical things that
people can be doing right now you talked
a little bit about open ai's products
chat GPT they also have Dolly too and
and others what are some of like the
Practical things that you think that
marketers can do today to start getting
themselves educated because I do want to
touch on in a second some of the watch
outs which are very very real for Brands
who have a lot to lose you know if
they're jumping into the space a little
too quickly
well actually let me reverse the
question because I think you know
oftentimes I'm interviewed by people
that I feel like are right there in
answering the questions that I'm always
enjoying
um other people's perspectives you're
you're heading up our Innovation agency
you know I know you well
um you're in it right now why don't you
answer that question in Reverse what do
you think you know I'll give you my two
second one and then you take it deeper
everyone needs to be tasting it I'm
petrified Avery that there are a ton of
people here who've read the headlines
but have not played with it
oh that's definitely the case so I feel
like everyone who's watching this right
now like your homework coming out of
this because Gary and I are framing this
up is like homework season and you know
I've worked three for more than five
years Gary and everything new you always
want to run on this is the one thing
that you're like let's run at it but
internally like let's really get
ourselves together let's really do our
homework because this is very very
powerful and a lot can go right but a
lot can also go wrong so instantly and
specifically I apologize
um the thing just so everyone's
listening because we clients it's very
quick to think oh we're an agency let's
make art out of this product for our
clients we can make something AI can
help us make something in two minutes a
minute that might take an hour for
someone in a day or canva or something
nature the problem is the source of the
creative is not clear enough yet and we
want to be very cautious about that so
for a lot of people here
play for it for yourself learn it play
use it internally to your point Avery
like Decks that our team are making for
each other you can do that that might
save you an hour to prep for a meeting
but if you're if you're doing something
on behalf of someone else be
understanding and thoughtful about some
of the stuff that's in the air right
yeah I think there's like four major
buckets where we see this being a useful
tool for us already internally and for
our partners like we work with Fortune
500 Brands and Enterprises um and at the
end of the day wherever consumers go
Brands need to understand the fact that
hundreds of millions of people are
already doing this and they're not just
using chat GPT they're creating AI
headshots and portraits and anyone can
be you know this new new type of artist
um there are like professional
generative AI artists and even a guy in
our team who's sort of been spearheading
this internally has been winning these
generative art competitions for like
real artists so like people are catching
on to it brands have to understand and I
think they're we're in this novelty
phase right now we're like okay great
chat GPT wrote my script and I'm Ryan
Reynolds like that is the novelty that
is getting attention because there's
relevance in this but I think we're
about to shift into more of the utility
component and generative AI can be
useful for strategy being a strategic
partner can be useful for copywriting
um even training certain models so they
sound like I'm in the voice of Gary
vaynerchuk when right like you can trade
it over time to visual creation like
asset production anyone who's ever
worked in agency knows there's a lot of
resizing and a lot of formatting and a
lot of production help and and we'll
hear from some of those partners and
then lastly I also think this ongoing
sort of ideation and ongoing Community
Management there can be a lot of
Automation in this that exists today and
people are feeling a little like oh is
this going to take away the jobs of
creatives and you know of of thinkers
and to us exactly what you said at the
top of this call it's and not or it's
right now it's a supplemental thing
um so that's what I'm seeing on my side
I need to just say something uh Troy
Denson in the YouTube comments said that
chat GPT said the Jets won't win the
Super Bowl until 2078. so I'll be
walking away from this stream right now
and going to work out and eat well
because I need to survive until that day
that would put me at 103 Avery and I'm
very focused on that so thank you Troy
for the information
what about the fear you know I think you
know some I saw someone say oh
um you know like the real question is
what's this going to do the job market
and I think it's very clear that this
technology is so profound that there
will be a scenario where it is able to
do things that humans are currently
being paid for however much like the
tractor in farming those humans went on
to do other things that were impactful
the critical thinking of using AI or all
together different things you know as
you know because you're on top of things
we've been talking about autonomous cars
taking truck drivers jobs for a decade
I've been hearing AI is going to take
jobs forever now it's here to your point
we don't have like the Uber of
autonomous trucks yet where we can have
that conversation
any hot take any intuition what are you
hearing
people especially internally we have a
lot we have thousands of creatives who
work
people are like hey
something I need to watch out for it's
actually something that they need to
learn and embrace and understand I think
a lot of our success at Vayner has come
from embracing change understanding
what's happening and skating to where
the puck is going
um because there will be prompt engineer
jobs we already see some people who
really get this their prompts are
getting better their output is getting
better it's just like you mentioned
Adobe or canva like it's a tool you need
to understand how to use the tool and
now I think we can call this homework
season is a time for brand marketers and
really anyone to spend time
understanding these tools so they can
effectively leverage them in this sort
of next era of the internet
Joey says I use text AI to write a blog
post and I was amazed at how effective
it was in helping me expand on my
thoughts completely mind-blown I think
you mentioned it earlier again everybody
loves the whole concept of or you know
where I sit on this there's a there's a
pandemic it's called being obsessed with
or instead of understanding and I think
the co-creating thought partner that AI
will be for copywriters is going to be
profound you know it's going to be a
training wheels you know some people use
classical music some people use a glass
of wine some people use going to the
cabin in the woods to like actually help
them write and think and put pen to
paper
um I actually think AI is going to be a
much more effective version of that
psychology
um and I'm I'm pretty excited about that
super excited Gary where do you think
that this is sort of heading in the now
and the next for marketers just as we
get ready to have our next guest on
do I have two minutes before the next
guest yeah cool uh so I just wanted to
know the timing um you know I think I
think you know you know this I'm a I'm I
hate that the world obsesses about
yesterday tactically not not learn from
it I think that people overly
you know try to figure out tomorrow that
I'm obsessed with the concept of today
the now event is it's here and every
single marketer every single operator
every single Creator and every single
human who's watching this needs to leave
at the end of this hour but uh and
literally listen to the platforms that
are here and go create accounts and go
taste there's it's just here we've
touched on some of the ways that you
have to be thoughtful copyright
trademark you have to be a little
thoughtful for commercial use but
yeah very AKA we're not doing it and we
always do everything so you know
um but you must you must use the
Serendipity of watching this today in
the middle of a Wednesday to be like
okay I've been putzing around there's
some people talking about it Avery
like this is the worst or this is the
best and literally haven't used it yet
so that's the answer is go go ride the
bike go don't don't have thoughts about
what swimming is going to feel like jump
in the pool and swim that's that's uh
that's the game
all right amazing Andrea we'll let you
pull up the next guest thank you thanks
to you both all right we're gonna bring
John up next John Licata who is the
chief of innovation at Sap's future Hub
and his his mission is to uncover
emerging Trends ahead of mainstream
thinking welcome John
hey everybody how you doing hey Gary
John how are you good good to finally
connect so much brother all right break
it down for a shot first of all your
background's epic awesome AI generated
just for you
um
give it to us my man just like
pontificate here I won't even go I'll
give you the floor up front like what
you know obviously you probably were
listening I assume you didn't just sign
in you know what do you agree with what
do you want to expand on what what do
these people need to know yeah I mean
first of all I really think that you're
right we have to jump in the pool and we
have to play and unfortunately right now
you're seeing some companies almost
bring in
um a an AI hammer and playing
whack-a-mole to fix things without
actually trying them and I think that's
definitely premature
I think that we need to figure out how
we can be augmented by Ai and become
better I mean you mentioned in in your
your monologue about you know the the
ability to maybe write better or have
the opportunity to have it help you and
I really think that's where we need to
go is the augmentation of of humans
um you can make a case for certain jobs
being replaced and Challenger gray and
Christmas talking about two and a half
million U.S jobs could be replaced by
chat gbt alone and Goldman Sachs I'm
talking about maybe 250 to 300 million
jobs globally from AI in general not
just from a generative AI but AI in
general but I think this is a this is a
time to try things out for upscaling to
see how you can maybe get better at
doing your job because if certain tasks
are automated
that might allow you to try to be more
Innovative to try new opportunities to
put in not just with you know creating
cool images but I really think that we
have to
um be prepared for moving from web Point
uh web 3.0 focused on digital assets and
really think about maybe 4.0 digitizing
trust this is where I think marketers
and businesses need to understand
because in the other day I was looking
and I came across a cool track from
Jay-Z guess what it wasn't Jay-Z and uh
you know this morning there was
something about Taylor Swift fans that
they were using her likeness and voice
but it's a personalized messages clearly
that wasn't her as well but the reality
is the IP the copywriting how do you how
do you it's easy to say we need to use
AI to get ethical and become more
responsible what does that mean systems
need to play with each other they need
to understand how do you navigate AI in
a world of compliance with
sustainability understanding if we're
going to play and jump in the pool
there's got to be some sort of framework
that we can make sure that we do it
right and I think that's you know my
family's from Italy Gary and I just saw
oh I hear it Johnny
Dave's you saw you know the Italian
government putting a pause on on General
Ai and I think that what you're what we
need to get to the point of is
understand can I trust the data as a
business as Vayner as sap can we move
forward have embedded AI in our
solutions that people can ultimately
trust and at the moment
you know you've seen some models that
are spinning out false information how
is a business or a marketer how can you
act on information you know one of our
our Executives put his bio in recently
and it and it and it came out at chat
GPT that he that he was deceased clearly
he was sitting next to me he was not
deceased by the way by the way just do
it right but brother just and you know
this just to remind everybody
this is deja vu I didn't trust all the
search results
like in 1996 they weren't always right
like you know with any Tech you know
that's funny though with I'm sure you're
saying this as well with every
technology we have to we have to have a
double check of thoughtfulness you know
to your point like how do you know if
it's real the biggest problem in the
world right now is people are just
reading headlines and just accepting
them as truth people also John as you
know they they see or find what they're
looking for people also take Wikipedia
as 100 truth while there's tens of
millions of people who for fun are
putting in Wikipedia that isn't
true like like you know like I mean
Google at early Yahoo like had many
things wrong about wine the first result
was an article about wine because the
guy knew where the girl knew how to do
SEO and it wasn't right yeah yeah you
know so you know
I'm just wondering will AI be the final
nail in the coffin where social media
was a preview to it of like when are
humans willing to become accountable to
become thoughtful again
because the intellectual laziness and or
the biasy to find what you're actually
looking for is a massive problem that
we're all affected by like the thought
that I would believe everything that
came out of chat GPT when it's 14
seconds old is asinine yeah that's crazy
yeah and you know I think we're going to
go come to a period Gary where you know
you have products that are made in the
USA products that are made in China you
can have to start seeing made in AI or
work that's complemented like this was
submitted by you know an AI bot or
something that shows people that there
was some complementary means but look
you and me have been around and I
remember back in the 90s when.com took
off when you you know with the wine
business and doing the great things that
you've done I was afraid to buy
something online my credit card
information
you know so now so what now I know my
UPS driver by his first name because
things come here so so frequently but I
think now
John think about about Uber back to just
technology if you told somebody 40 years
ago that they would have preferred their
14 year old to go into a strange man's
car yeah they don't know the man
absolutely like you'd rather your 14
year old to stay safe
is going in a stranger's car that was
literally the only thing my mom told me
not to do
yeah yeah knowledge exchanges are norms
all the time by the way little fun fact
the year 1800 83 of the labor force
worked on farms
and then tractors were invented
yeah no it's it's so cool to to think
about you know we we have to we have to
figure out a way that we we can leverage
intelligence in new ways and right now
you know it's it's great to put a a
query in and to get some sort of
intelligence for something that you need
maybe in that here and now but some of
those models haven't been updated since
2021. so you if I need to know something
I I would rather have the machines
um known John no Gary help us in our
moment that we're doing something
understand what are my business goals
what are my kpis and feed me information
that will allow me to make better
decisions have better customer personas
based on what's Happening Now people's
their buying habits change we don't have
one blanket Persona anymore and maybe AI
should be used more as an assisting tool
and and well when it becomes more
invisible we can become more active
you'll love this and you know this
there'll be no should AI is now a
technology like
Technologies like the gun the fork the
atomic bomb the internet like people are
going to use them for good for bad for
indifferent there's gonna be no should
there's Ai and it's going to be used for
all sorts of things
yeah and humans have proven the ability
everyone that in my circles that's
doomsday about this I'm like
the atomic bomb was invented
yeah you know like like like like a gun
was invented I promise you if we were
all hanging around when the gun was
invented and we were like we're like
wait a minute my sword is like like
humans are capable I also think the
blockchain's verification infrastructure
with an AI world you know I haven't
really put the you know the ingredients
are in my head I'm like wait a minute if
we're gonna need affirmation isn't this
the blockchain's core strength I wonder
if information going to the blockchain
as a way to create provenance and
resourcing and truth that could be
profound that's digital trust that's web
4.0 that we're going to be moving
forward and you know like even with nfts
uh you know like right now it right now
it's it's artwork but meant about IP and
exchanging these things that the AI can
help with so many different things Gary
that we can tackle and maybe we will
have the Jets win you know sooner than
with that call with that call look I
will both suffer as long as I see it 103
I'll be fine I'll be like hey you know
whatever you know
and are we done here Andrew all right go
so fast it goes so fast thank you so
much John we're gonna bring up Laura
Bowden who is a partner at Bain and
she's the architect of Bain Solutions
and marketing and has recently joined
arms with open AI in a partnership with
Coca-Cola that we're super interested in
hearing about welcome Laura
thank you
hi Laura how are you I'm great how are
you I'm well tell us uh tell us all
about this this exciting partnership
what what should we all collectively
learn from it
sure so I guess maybe what I'll start
with is you're kind of picking up on one
of the themes that you were talking
about AI is is here and you know it's
gonna be like 10 years ago when every
company board and CEO says well what are
we doing about digital you know now
we're going to have every CEO and board
saying well what are we doing about Ai
and so you know our perspective is that
every marketing organization has to have
a good answer to you know not just that
we're you know you giving the keys over
to generative AI in order to create all
of our content from here to Eternity but
but there's a lot of really useful
practical applications of AI across the
whole marketing value chain that you
know maybe aren't quite so flashy and
sexy but actually will create much
better outcomes
and you know the partnership that we
have with open Ai and the philosophy
that that coke has brought to this
actually also Echoes some of the other
themes that you've brought up all
already you know number one is we just
need to start learning what it can do
and where is it useful and where do we
test the limits and you know what do we
need to be mindful of
as the tip of the iceberg that allows us
to unlock more opportunity across the
whole marketing organization
and yeah our partnership with open AI is
very much structured around yeah we've
you open AI has created the technology
they haven't had the capacity to be able
to think through all the different
applications and so we've been
challenged to say you know well what can
we be doing what are the various
different use cases where do we see you
know value coming out of those use cases
and then more importantly actually and
sort of important to our business how
does that work
um what do you have to rewire in order
to be able to get the value out of it
where would you actually start changing
decision rules if you know you've got
new steps in the in the process or ways
that you know individuals can be
empowered to do things that they
couldn't do before
yeah I think that's right what do you
think uh actually just a fun one Laura
what what was like the most aha moment
for you when you were like uh oh this is
a big big deal you know we all kind of
have those moments with big new
technologies
I'm in that perfect age where my entire
career has almost been hitting like web
one Web Two web you know
um
yeah so what was yours with AI you know
what were you like you know because I'm
sure given your
career and all the great successes you
know
like me I looked at startups that were
doing AI four five six years ago and
very quickly I was like okay this is
like half-assed machine learning or I a
lot of them were just like oh these are
just apis this isn't really you know
when did you have like the oh man this
is like when did you taste it or when
what did you see what was the AHA
so yeah very much from a marketing lens
the excitement that I have around
generative AI in particular is that I
think marketing has lived for far too
long with the silos between brand and
creative and performance and generative
AI is this awesome bridge that will
actually finally bring them together so
that those who are coming up with the
most creative con Concepts will be able
to finally prove that they drive
performance and you know and and I think
the technology is super exciting for
being able to more quickly and easily
optimize the content in a way that then
you can see the performance value of it
I mean I know we all know I think the
thing there Laura as you know is
if one is interested in creating that
accountability
my my argument to your point in addition
additive to what you just said is oh
wait a minute a lot of service providers
are really enjoying the pulls in the
fingers that it's Media or creative's
fault like if people have been asking me
lately because we've been exploding like
why is vaynermedia winning or why did
this go so well or why is it so hot I'm
like really the actual answer is we
haven't we have a thirst to be
accountable that our marketing is
working
um you're absolutely right this is
definitely a technology that can create
that capacity it's just that the
industry for 30 years has really enjoyed
the non-accountability
somewhat I mean we've been studying what
we call marketing leaders for a decade
or or more than that at this point where
we look at the organizations that are
driving sales and and gaining share and
the things that they do different than
everybody else and throughout that
decade is that the leaders those who are
growing they have that accountability
they optimize you constantly they're
always testing and they've built that
bridge so that they are
um including the create creative and
brand teams into the into the
accountability now if we could say that
all day long I agree with you there's
still many organizations who don't care
but I think more and more I also think a
lot to your point I think on a good day
that group is 20 and of that 20 there's
another 50 that is accountable because
they're sales organizations with some
marketing overlay which gets them to
that accountability of business but
that's that's on a tangent final
thoughts because I don't want to I want
I mean I want to make sure we've touched
on everything you've you maybe wanted to
touch on is there anything that this
audience should be thinking about needs
to know about like giving you the floor
what should what should that be
well my perspective you know obviously
all the headlines are about the
generative content and creative
applications but when you stop to think
about it there are 25 other applications
of even generative AI within what
marketing organization can do whether
it's leveraging unstructured data to be
able to improve improve audience
targeting or whether it's you know
actually recreating the brief process in
order to include more data sources and
make the briefs smarter you know those
aren't the things that are going to be
you know like the coke partnership
garnering all of the headlines but I
think that's actually where a lot of the
value is going to to lie the
practicality of it yeah the not exciting
stuff but the you know the the Practical
stuff that will drive impact for
everybody who's watching who's not in
the marketing world the brief is like a
starting point document into Laura's
point
a lot you know many things that happen
in marketing are incredibly vulnerable
when the when the brief is too vanilla
and I you know I was listening carefully
to what Laura said I think that's
absolutely right you you to use this
technology to give teeth
to the brief for a lot of people will
end up being a very practical
operational enhancement I think Lord to
your point and we kind of touched on it
earlier if you heard a lot of the
internal stuff is going to be really
really actionable right now while I do
think are you also Laura hearing a lot
of people at your level kind of chirping
about the copywriter trademark fears on
the creative generative stuff
yeah
um and I think at some point we'll find
ways to be able to create the right
guidelines and kind of guardrails around
that the other piece that I think we
can't ignore is the unintended bias that
comes from you know the models being
trained on a lot of history that none of
us first you know want to repeat
of course of course
um
Andrea how much I'm just I'm a little I
feel
yeah I gotta go right because this one's
going to lickety-splits so thank you so
much Lauren thank you Gary appreciate
you are joining on we'll be talking a
lot about AI going forward but so nice
to see you and happy happy Holidays
happy Passover all right let's bring
Avery back on up we've got a whole bunch
of demos and interesting stuff to share
with everybody and very excited to First
bring up
um Megan from Jasper Megan keaney
Anderson she's the head of marketing at
Jasper it's a generative AI platform
that helps creators break through
writer's block create original art and
adapt their content for different
formats languages and tones it sounds
like it does everything I can't wait to
hear about this one yeah thank you so
much fun thank you so much for being
here with us Megan um I love Jasper so
super excited that's awesome
so yeah tell us a little bit about
yourself tell us a little bit about what
Jasper does and it's a little bit of
context for everyone who's watching
we're now actually going to see a few
demos see how some of the stuff actually
works and hear from some leading experts
who are building tools in this era so
again let's talk about Jasper what is it
what does it do yeah definitely so so
Jasper initially emerged as a answer to
that like visceral commonly held pain
point of staring at a blank page and not
knowing what to create or not being able
to
um to communicate well your ideas I
think that like for the longest time you
know the main thing that has stood in
the way of some of our best ideas has
been our ability to communicate them
well and at scale
add to that that most marketers today
are under just enormous intense content
demands and have either flatter
diminishing budgets so um Jasper emerged
as an AI assistant to help creators
marketing teams kind of
um reduce the amount of time they're
spending on the content production so
that they can spend more time on things
like ideation and editing and original
research and all that good stuff that's
where it began today it still answers
that pain but the other emerging pain
that we're finding is that you know AI
is this phenomenal incredible thing
but the outputs even though they're
beautifully written they're pretty
generic right you've all experienced
this in any AI tool that you've used so
where we're kind of heading now with
Jasper is the ability to do some
training of our model around your own
brand voice and style so you can get on
brand AI assisted content anywhere
amazing and how do you get into Jasper
how did you get hooked on AI you know I
was I was perfectly happy in my last job
I was having a great time and then
Jasper reached out and
um I tried the software and the tool and
it was like one of those moments that
Gary was just talking about where you
realize in an instant how transformative
this thing is going to be in the way
that we create in the way that we
communicate and the way that we
understand the world around us and I
just had to be a part of that so
um I joined the company in September
it's been a wild uh fun interesting run
since then uh Chachi PT came out in
November so that brought a whole new
level of awareness to AI as a tool and
we really see our role as like we're
squarely focused on businesses and
really marketing teams we see our role
as trying to help these teams figure out
how do they set standards for AI and
their companies how do they roll this
out what part of of the process should
this
accelerate right so we're trying to
really position
um as a as an aid to these companies
that are trying to figure it out for the
first time yeah I'm seeing a lot of
people in the chat saying they actually
have used Jasper and they use it
themselves who is the whole audience who
are the people who and companies who are
signing up for Jasper
um I know it's some Brands I know it's
some small businesses some individual
entrepreneurs like who's sort of the
core Target and what are some of the
main ways that people actually use some
of your Suite of tools yeah so we
there's really kind of two audiences
that we speak to
um the the first and where we feel like
we're really the most differentiated is
in
um businesses so growing businesses that
again are dealing with lots of content
demands they've got a team of marketers
that are all creating content across
different Avenues and formats
um and so that's sort of our primary
buyer is like the director of content or
the CMO who's trying to keep up with
their own content strategy we also see a
collection of you know Freelancers and
individual bloggers and bigger companies
that are sort of using this as a secret
weapon
um and we find that that Jasper is
pretty great at being able to flex to
both but we really come alive when used
across a team to coordinate um and
collaborate on things like product
launch campaigns all right so let's see
some magic let's see how this actually
works who are nice enough to prepare a
little bit of a demo so we'll pull that
up and see how Jasper actually sort of
comes to life
um in a real life use case
awesome sounds great
yeah
I'll talk through it so this there's a
this is also where you get to see how
slow of a typer I am
um so so I think about you know there's
all sorts of ways you can use AI but as
a marketer I think about how to three
different types the first is to
um help write an original piece of
content so you maybe are stuck with that
intro line you need help completing it
then the second is how do you take that
piece of original content that you've
written and repackage it into different
formats usually we're not just writing a
blog post we're doing a full-fledged
campaign with a landing page and an
email and social content and so how do
you take a core ebook or blog post and
turn it into a full span of content
um and do that very quickly so that's
what you can see just happen there turn
that that intro paragraph into a tweet
and then the final use case I really
love is adapting content to different
audiences or different languages so here
I'm changing the above content into
Mandarin
um so you're able to sort of very
quickly not just translate but truly
localize content into different
languages which is pretty powerful for
global companies and then adapting it to
different audiences so for example say I
want to speak to small business owners
versus Enterprises or one industry
versus another it can take that content
and and really adapt it so that it's
more relevant to the person that uh
you're targeting in a given campaign
this is amazing just the level of
customization that's possible
um in such a quick period of time you
know you're just talking about typing
speed and it seems like Jasper is very
quick yeah and one more thing I'll call
out here um I should have mention is
you'll notice in this video I'm in a
Google doc I'm not in the Jasper
platform although I certainly could have
done this in the Jasper platform I think
the most powerful thing about Jasper is
that it follows you around wherever you
need to create online
um so if you're on LinkedIn you want to
use it to write a LinkedIn post it's
just a simple little purple cursor that
you call up with a keystroke if you're
in your email or your CMS or
um any other platform that you use you
can have Jasper as a sort of invisible
layer beneath all that
that's amazing Jasper comes with you
across your journey where you're the
main character so now last and most
important question how do you handle
like the questions that you probably get
from CMOS and
um entrepreneurs on where is this data
coming from like how does licensing work
I know my lawyers made us ask what we're
asking us that when we were sort of
starting to work with y'all so where
where does all this information come
from again yeah so a lot of the
questions we get around both that and
then also like hey the the content that
I put into Jasper where does that go is
that used to train larger models do you
know is that secure so it's two sides of
that question so for the first question
around ownership
um so Jasper doesn't own your content
you own your content there is a debate
right now around copyright so there's a
difference between ownership and
copyright right copyright just means can
I take this to the U.S copyright office
and put that trademark stamp on it yeah
and the guidance on that has been talked
about in Prior sessions the main
guidance that we provide people is
if you want to copyright something it
needs to be a blend of AI and human
creation right you can't just put a
prompt in get an answer and hit publish
and frankly you shouldn't do that anyway
all content you create with AI should be
edited and contributed jointly with a
human Creator it's meant to be an
accelerant not a replacement so if there
is a good healthy blend of human ideas
in there and for your own writing that
gets more into the realm of what you can
copyright and own
um on the what of your data that goes
into Jasper kind of what happens to that
that's also yours to own we're not using
that to retrain the models
um you know with the exception of your
sort of custom model we're not sending
that back to like third party
um language models or anything like that
that is yours to own within Jasper
amazing well Megan we could probably
talk about legal terms all day but thank
you so much for joining us for sharing a
little bit about what Jasper does and
looking forward to doing more with y'all
in the future really appreciate your
time love to be here thank you for
having us thank you Megan all right
Avery next up we have Mickey Friedman
he's the co-founder and CEO of flair AI
which is an AI powered creative tool
that designs marketing collateral around
your Brand's Unique Style
thanks so much for joining us
thank you so much thank you for coming
um I think we have like one of the most
you know gen Z like meeting stories
we've been on Twitter because I actually
saw a demo of the tool that you were
building and I saw it picking up some
steam and going a little bit viral and I
reached out to you because I was really
impressed and you know we started uh
exploring a partnership shortly
thereafter so I want to thank you for
taking the time um to be here with us
today and demo the tool that you are
building
um at your startup Flair but before we
get into all of that
um can you tell us a little bit about
yourself and sort of What attracted you
to AI what was that light bulb moment
for you
sure well my background is in a
traditional machine learning I've
supported teams at Adobe and Tesla
around 2021 I was really into the
generative Arts scene that's how it
started and eventually a friend
approached me and told me that his dad
needed to generate marketing collateral
for his wine shop so it started off very
small originally I thought I would be
one of the first AI enabled design and
marketing agencies because I was only
working with a few clients but as I
started to automate my workflow I
thought what if we what if we were able
to make this self-serving what if we
were able to create this little design
agency in a box that could help small
businesses but also marketing and design
agencies do their work and that's how
Flair was born I would really describe
us as an AI power design and creative
testing tool that integrates with your
Brand's customer data to generate
personalized and highly converting
product photos
yeah and it's just come such a long way
even in the last few months so can you
talked a little bit about this idea of
using it to create marketing collateral
for small businesses what are some of
the use cases that you see already
happening for Flair today and what are
some of the potential use cases you see
of Tomorrow sure so right now um I would
say that our customers are separated in
three groups we've got small businesses
and they're usually generating product
photo shoots for their e-commerce shops
we've got design agencies and marketing
agencies using Flair and they're sort of
using it as a creative testing tool to
you know test out different
um products and different themes with
their customers and focus groups and
then the third segment that we see are
Freelancers who are using Flair to
generate
um you know concepts for clients and um
so that's sort of how it's being used
right now we've got several thousand
weekly active users at the moment and
it's growing every single week in the
future though I really see this as a
tool that will allow a business
businesses to really personalize their
content for different Target
demographics so one use case that I see
is for example if you'd like to generate
an ad with a human selling your soda
product you can design your product
photo shoot on flare and then you can
generate different models based on the
age group and locations of your general
audience to really convert them so
that's where I see it going in the
future and I've actually prepared a demo
that shows how you can do that
let's see some magic let's bring up the
demo um and then Mickey maybe you can
sort of talk us through what we're
seeing as it's kind of coming to life in
real time definitely let's do it
foreign so this part of the demo is
showing off the props feature and they
work just the way that they would in a
real photo shoot so here you can see
we're dragging in a three-step platform
um next we're going to bring in a rose
and one of the most useful features for
props is that you can adjust the color
to align with your Brand's style guide
so I just made that orange I can change
the color of the platform as well and
add as many props as I like to the same
composition so there's really not like
no limit to what you can do last I'm
going to drag in an orange and place it
on the platform if this this is a
citrusy skin care product
all right
um as you can see when you drag in a
prop it auto completes the prompt so you
don't really have to do too much prompt
engineering you can edit it if you want
but really uh it does most of the work
for you takes only a few seconds to
generate
and here's your final result as you can
see the props become realistic the
lighting the Shadows are consistent and
every detail of your product uh the
words in the label Etc are all preserved
uh so that's that's one of the ways that
Flair allows you to control the overall
composition of what you're trying to
produce
next uh this is a demo that shows you uh
how we can generate human models to sell
your products
so you can start off with a template and
it's super easy all you have to do is
resize and position your product within
the template click generate
takes a few seconds as well
and then you get a hyper realistic
result of a human selling your product
now the next step will be to basically
generate humans based off of the
localization and the age of your target
audience so that it can really sell the
product better in a more um
tailored manner
yeah amazing one thing that I love about
it I know I think the viral post I'm
talking about was one that Mary had a
Chanel bottle and like these really cool
flowers so Brands can actually bring
their products into this as well right
and then use generative backgrounds I
know I've done so many product photo
shoots everything from beer to Skin Care
Brands where it's in the snow it's the
pumpkins it's in sand
um so this seems like a major sort of
Time Saver
um you know but you have to get good at
prompt engineering Mickey what are your
recommendations for people who are just
starting out in their AI journey and
maybe looking to get better at prompts
there's probably some tips and tricks
that you have from the you know many
many hours you've poured into this
understanding how to optimize Flair
prompt engineering is really difficult
and uh what we've worked on Flair is to
create different ways to actually make
prompt engineering easier so for example
when you log on to Flair for the first
time I'd advise clicking through
different templates that we have the
templates are based off of Highly
converting product photo shoots designer
ads that have you know really taken off
so we have basically reversed engineered
how to recreate those photo shoots with
your own products so instead of writing
out a really complicated prompt you can
click on a photo
see the prompt behind it and edit it to
produce the ad of your dreams so I would
I would recommend starting off with
templates on flare and I think that with
stable diffusion and Dolly and other
tools you just have to give it you just
have to give it a few tries and then you
start start to get the hang of it but
yeah like our goal is to make prompting
as easy as possible which is why we've
added props and templates
amazing so Mickey how can um listeners
to this get access to Flair is this
something that is still in beta is it
fully publicly available how does it
work
flares and beta but you can go to
app.flair.ai to give it a try uh the
human feature is going to be deployed
sometime later next week uh so you know
stay tuned for that but you can totally
play around with props right now and you
can totally generate as many photos as
you'd like with uh you know the
templates that we have available and you
have full flexibility to edit those
templates as well so the customizations
that you can perform are endless
amazing Mickey thank you so much for
sharing a little bit sharing the
platform and talking about your journey
at Flair AI I know you've you know had
this incredible
um upper trajectory in all things
generated AI so appreciate you taking
the time to join us and share a little
bit about your insights thank you so
much Avery this is great have a great
day you too boy that was magic I love
that
all right we got another one Avery we're
gonna bring up Paul Aaron who is the CEO
and co-founder of addition and AI
research and development company
exploring the future of creativity
Edition works with Brands and agencies
like the New York Times and Unilever to
develop data-driven insights content and
experiences using generative models
welcome Paul we're so happy to have you
here
hey thanks for having me hey Paul thank
you for being here we're so excited to
hear a little bit about your insights um
and share a little bit of information on
how Edition works I am an audition power
user I'd say from some of the recipes
that you all have out there
um so I'm really excited to share with
the marketing for the now audience
um a bit about the cool stuff that y'all
are building
um so first can you tell a little us a
little bit about yourself and a little
bit about audition
yeah sure so my background's in
marketing and advertising and I've been
in the industry for I guess about 15 to
20 years and I started out as a digital
executive producer in like the I guess
mid-2000s and you know it was always
kind of focused on
how our marketers and Brands adapting to
you know the the technology of of the
moment which back then was mobile and
social
and a couple years ago I I just kind of
had the feeling that there was too much
for for Brands and agencies to keep
track of there were just like too many
channels too many data sources and
I felt like AI was going to begin to
play this outsized role
um in the marketing uh creative and
strategic process and so I teamed up
with somebody I knew for a long time who
has an AI and machine learning
background and we just sort of tapped
into some of you know our our friends
um you know industry colleagues within
you know Brands and agencies and and
just started
putting you know putting AI to work and
in the process I think we've you know
we've had the privilege of of
collaborating with a lot of amazing
agencies and amazing Enterprise orgs and
really kind of getting a unique sense of
how
how the market is is starting to kind of
use this Tech
um so yeah it's been it's been really
wild and fascinating how has chat how is
like the chat GPT moment changed your
inbound lead flow I can imagine like as
soon as chat GPT kind of entered like
mainstream Consciousness a lot of Brands
and marketers started being like Oh yeah
I need to figure out AI
yeah yeah there have been a few
watershed moments over the last year but
that was definitely the biggest and I
think what was
really amazing is it allowed people to
kind of have that experience firsthand
of of really you know sort of being
amazed and Blown Away by the capability
of generative AI
um I remember the first time you know I
guess for me it was you know a couple
years ago now where I was really like
awestruck and it's almost like a
religious experience where you realize
that you know machines are becoming
incredibly creative incredibly you know
lifelike and human-like and what they're
able to achieve and so yeah I think for
you know for the the world to sort of
have that moment um you know that was
what GPT did and and for us that you
know that just really helped um in terms
of not having to do as much education
right so uh we started the company in
2021 and
a lot of what we did in the beginning
was just teaching people what generative
AI was and you know we would you know
whip up a bunch of demos to kind of show
them rather than tell them
um but but yeah now now most people kind
of have had that experience and so it
really makes the conversation more
tangible
well that's a nice segue Paul
um let's pull up some demos uh addition
can do a bunch of really cool things and
you know for folks who are listening to
this I would encourage all of them to
check out your recipes that are
available on your website
um there's just a lot of fun stuff you
can do I know there's a Super Bowl
generator and you know some like
synthetic insights I think the you know
first experiment I had leveraging
editions models were you had trained a
model on award-winning creative ads and
as someone who spent a lot of time
judging and writing Awards I was like oh
my God this is hysterical and amazing
the most contextually right reference
for an ad agency or a marketing uh
executive because we all know what those
should sound like
um but I know there's a bunch of uh
really cool things that you guys have
sort of up and ready so yeah let's let's
see the magic happen let's bring up the
demo
yeah sure yeah so as you're bringing it
up I'll say you know we we put a lot of
these things out as as sort of education
and um you know this particular uh AI
recipe is going to leverage uh news
search to generate insights and you know
insights are something that are you know
obviously very important to marketers
and we've been really fascinated at how
systems like gpt4 can turn data into
insights so what's happening now is
based on a prompt
um the AI is going to go out it's going
to search the web to find a corpus of
data it's going to then use that
information
coupled with a bunch of training
examples of what make for really good
insights
and it's going to kind of fuse those
together into an Insight that's in the
style that I want and in this case we've
used these kind of like really pithy you
know one to two sentence inside examples
um
so yeah uh sorry I'm on my phone I'm
having a hard time reading it but oh no
worries um what is the inside find an
insight about how generative AI will
change the way that Brands uh interact
with the world and it's typing very fast
and saying gender of AI is often
perceived as a tool for automating tasks
but what if it evolves the way that
Brands communicate fostering deeper and
more meaningful interactions with
consumers verbatims and it starts to go
into different verbatims and what I like
is it's sourcing these verbatims which I
think is a difference from some of the
tools that we've seen
um even in earlier in this this episode
yeah yeah so again you know this is
really just to kind of
um you know sort of educate people about
different use cases
um but for some of the brands that we
work with we're scaling this you know
this process up on larger data sets so
rather than you know going out and
searching uh news articles
um you know which is kind of good if
you're you know an individual doing desk
research we're working with um large
Enterprises to put this technology on
top of first party data right so it can
kind of go through Reams and reams of
customer interviews and survey responses
and it can help them find little nuggets
of consumer insights in their data that
would otherwise take countless hours of
human time to unearth let's get very
practical just so everybody sort of
who's listening here understands what
that means how do you get Reams and
reams of data to feed your model like
what does that process look like
yeah so uh I guess it sort of depends on
if you have data to begin with but you
know if you're a Fortune 500 company
let's assume yeah yeah sure so
um generally what we work with is Text
data right so we're talking about
unstructured Text data and these models
are really really good at finding little
creative nuggets in data so you know
data sets that work really well are like
you know customer interviews or survey
responses or you know product reviews
and things like that
um social media content is also really
good so looking at you know like social
listening data or you know uh you know
forums and things like that
um AI will then be able to sort of
iteratively sort of like read through
that data
um you know we can kind of label that
data as needed we'll also transform that
data into something called embeddings so
that we can just do kind of intelligent
information retrieval which kind of
allows us to let's say put one of these
systems on top of you know tens of
thousands of documents
and pull in the right documents in the
right moment to you know to generate an
Insight or you know generate content or
any of the other you know potential use
cases so what I'll say is it's it's
gotten infinitely easier right the data
prep process is has gotten infinitely
easier compared to where it was just a
couple years ago and so if you're a
marketer within you know a big company I
would say you know dive in and like you
know don't be afraid because
um it's it's quick you know it's not
like it's not like the AI projects from
a couple years ago that required you
know massive amounts of data cleaning um
because these models are so powerful
they don't they don't need data to be
incredibly structured yeah I think that
you know from my perspective one of the
biggest use cases we've seen is using AI
to synthesize large amounts of data
whether that's pulling from publicly
available sources or you know something
that's brand owned it can be incredibly
powerful and then of course you have to
like vet it and check it it's not 100
right now but synthesizing that
information is an incredible insights
generator it's an incredible strategic
tool for companies who invest a lot in
these surveys and sometimes they're like
so what and you're like okay hey I can
help you figure out that so what so you
know you all have also been in this game
for a while I know you did really cool
um chat Bots um with companies like
Dollar Shave Club anything you can share
that's sort of in the wild that people
might be able to see as a reference of
how this actually comes to life
externally
yeah sure
um we actually just launched this
um generator for job descriptions if you
go to generate dot skillsengine.com
um that's something that just released
and we have a bunch of other things that
are coming out um that are more sort of
customer facing right so you know we're
really interested in how Brands can use
generative AI to to engage with
customers
um so what I would also say is um
subscribe to our sub stack it's uh
edition.substack.com and we've got a
bunch of new things coming out that
we'll you know we'll be sharing as well
over the coming the coming weeks Amazing
Paul thank you so much for your time
always wonderful to connect with you and
hear your insights and all the cool
stuff that you're building all the
recipes you are cooking up at Edition so
thank you for joining us um and and
being on marketing for the now
awesome thanks for having me thanks Paul
all right Avery you got one last one and
it's a good one we're gonna bring up Ave
parasnas who is the founder and CEO of
typeface typeface is the Enterprise
grade generative AI application to
supercharge personalized content
creation we're super happy to have you
Abe thanks for joining us of course
great to be here hey everyone hello how
are you doing great
I'm so excited that you were able to
join us we haven't yet like officially
started working with typeface but I've
been reading a lot about what you guys
are building and I'm so curious for you
to share with um our listeners
um a little bit of of sort of what's
cooking so you were a senior executive
at Adobe for many many years and then
you just launched typeface so tell us
what problem typeface solves
yeah I mean first of all thanks uh for
having uh me here and lots of fun
conversations uh lots of exciting
Innovations even Mickey I saw earlier a
little bit I've known Mickey and there
are lots of people doing really cool and
exciting stuff and so happy to share a
little bit uh for us actually it is a
little bit unusual to be talking right
now about typeface because there's so
much hype and noise around generative AI
but we actually started
a little bit before any of the stable
diffusion or chat GPT and the core
thesis every was very simple as you said
I spent seven or eight years at Adobe a
CTO and talking to a lot of the
creatives as well as the digital
marketers uh through that business one
thing that became clear is everyone
struggles with content in the way either
they can produce high quality on-brand
content with lots of manual effort or
you can get speed and personally like
get a lot of content out there but
trying to do high velocity content while
preserving your brand and voice is a
consistent problem that everyone was
describing and then we basically felt
generative AI represents a unique
movement where you can actually use the
power of these generative models but if
you can bring it to the Enterprise
systems and workflows and I'll share a
little bit more in a bit that is the
real problem which is marry the benefits
of generative platform within your
Enterprise workflows in your own brand
voice
absolutely and I think that's a huge
thing like so many entering prizes that
we work with are like this is all cool
but like how does this work with what my
systems how does this work with what my
teams can do how does this work with my
legal team it's a very big problem to
solve and and you know one that you
probably saw many times over in your
previous world and you know I love this
transition of of you know Executives who
have been in sort of leading web 2
companies and now into this next era of
the internet because I think it speaks
to what consumers are looking for in the
internet which is something that's more
immersive and personalized and ownable
but personalized is going from like you
know something that you know give you a
little bit of a targeted ad to like
everyone expects to be the main
character of the internet these days
um and I think generative AI really
enables that so what are the some of the
products that y'all are building at
typeface and and also who is your target
consumer yeah so uh at its core really
the way you should think about typeface
we are building three
capabilities for Enterprise customers
and so our audience really is firmly
Enterprise companies which are either
small and medium but also all the way up
to kind of Fortune 500 Fortune 50
companies and the Three core
capabilities are building first and
foremost we are building something
called type phase graph which is really
all about bringing all the modalities
all your content uh into a new kind of a
generative Hub and one challenge with a
lot of the current generative platforms
is chat GPD stable division Dali mid
Journey amazing technical breakthroughs
but that's not how your customers think
about actually telling the stories for
them their stories are their Instagram
posts their blog posts their shopping
publication on their e-commerce and so
the second thing we have built which is
very exciting getting a lot of positive
response is something called blend and
blend in an easy way to understand is
take all the large models that are out
there that amazing Innovation that's
happening and then affinitize it
uniquely in your company's voice for
your audiences your data your products
your catalogs and then with one click
being able to publish it on various
platforms and various outputs that you
care about and so blend is kind of our
secret sauce of taking the large Brain
if you will of the large models but then
making it uniquely understand the
language of your business your customers
yours audiences
well let's see some of the magic let's
bring up the demo so we can see how some
of this stuff actually works
um we'll pull it up on the screen so
people can see how this magical
Innovation Works
great and so we are only going to show a
small sliver but as I said one of the
issues with the models if you use
something like stable diffusion this
shows what's the problem today where
when you try to generate images of a
product they don't really recognize the
brand and so what you see here is what
we call blend where you can upload your
own assets just give us your website
assets and then we'll train it
seamlessly and then in one click we can
do a multi-modal generation and by that
if you look at something like an
Instagram post here it will generate
images using the best image models
preserving the fine details of your
product it will generate the text copy
in your voice again being trained on how
you speak to your customers and then
really drive all of that and so what you
see here is this notion around
generating many many different kinds of
artifacts blog posts I know Paul just
talked about job descriptions and so one
of the things we have in fact we just
announced last week with one of the
largest HR providers company name
Sequoia that they are going to enable
typeface for hundreds of their customers
to do all employee communication job
descriptions blog posts Etc
that's amazing
a very clear need right also helping you
empathize your communication and you
know leverage best practices with HR
Communications in the way that managers
deliver feedback and you know work with
their employees
um so how does typeface differ you
talked a little bit about how there's
such a hype cycle especially in the Bay
area right now of everybody's launching
a generative AI startup how is typeface
different from some of the other
offerings that um you know you see in
the market today
yeah I mean first we are focused
squarely on solving problems for
Enterprises that's really our Focus but
really the three key differentiators
first we are multimodal because your
stories cross text images video they
don't go through each modality so first
we bring all your content types in one
system and let use generative AI to tell
multi-modal stories number two we think
the next chapter of generative AI is
something called Affinity AI where you
affinitize these models uniquely to your
company's customers and audiences and
our blend engine is the first one that
does something like Affinity AI for
customers and then last but not the
least every there's a lot of concerns
around brand safety brand governance the
voice of Michael I don't want this to
generate some offensive content and so
we have built-in guard rails in typeface
uh called typeface safe that gives
Enterprises control over what content
actually their brand should be
associated with and how do they control
it how do they deliver it safely
I think that's so important because at
the end of the day like a lot of these
big brands have a lot to lose and you
know maybe something that was
appropriate in 1997 is not appropriated
2023 and
um you know even training them these
models on past Behavior might not be the
future direction for the company who
might be on a reinvention journey
um so by the way I'm seeing Eagle says
you want to know each guest website we
will post these after because I know
everyone wants to see and learn more
about some of these companies and what
folks are building
um but Ave you know working in AI you
must be amazed every day at sort of
these capabilities what are some of like
the wildest use cases that you've seen
of generative AI
um to you know help Enterprises
reimagine their communication with
consumers anything that was like a huge
Watershed or light bulb moment for you
yeah I think I'll give you two uh one on
technology and one on The Human Side on
the technology side I mean as you said
we we all have seen lots of changes but
simply the rate of change and the
ability to take completely new forms of
mediums and by the way right now if we
think text and image is mind blowing
wait until we start seeing in the coming
months video 3D animation immersive and
so just the ability to create immersive
stories simply by expressing what's in
your mind that is something that has
never happened so this level of
democratization is unbelievable what's
actually exciting for me is the human
element I know there is a lot of concern
around will this displace jobs and will
take jobs away but actually what is
going to be probably more profound is
once everyone is empowered to create
these Amazing Stories and storytelling
it is going to create a whole new set of
jobs for people who could never actually
be able to express themselves in these
rich mediums and we are going to see an
explosion of these creative jobs that I
think is going to change people from
just Road automation oriented things to
apply their own creativity and their
mind in telling their story so that's
actually going to be pretty exciting in
the years that's such a good call out
because I think about myself I'm not
very good at visual communication but
with you know some of the tools that are
now available in free like I can be an
artist and I can you know design things
that look so beautiful and impressive
just by using like the skill set of of
writing and of communication so I love
that you know point that you made
earlier on multi-modality um which I
think we're going to see a lot more of
because the reality is people do not
just
um you know think in in written format
or in visuals um we're starting to see a
lot more happening in the world of of 3D
and animation unfortunately Runway
couldn't be here today but they're
building some really cool stuff and
we'll have them on soon
um but Ave thank you so much for taking
the time to be here with us I know y'all
are very busy and in the middle of
building this new company and we are
wishing you all the success in the world
um thank you for joining us on marketing
for the now thanks Avery
thanks Abe and thank you Avery this was
so informative
I learned a lot and I want to thank
everybody up in the chat who's been you
know taking the time out of their day to
join us and to learn like Gary said at
the top of this hour it's homework
season so this is the time to really get
to get to Hands-On with some of these
tools educate yourself educate your
organizations
um we've covered a very high level look
at just a peek at how generative AI is
supercharging digital marketing and
changing consumer behavior on the
internet forever so if you're looking if
you're more of a you know learner who
absorbs we actually wrote a Vader 3
white paper that you can check out on
our website vayner3.com learn marketer's
guide to generative AI so I encourage
you all to check that out thank you
Andrea for hosting such a fantastic
session and uh we will catch everybody
on the next one
yeah we'll definitely be weaving AI into
probably every episode going forward but
also for those of you that are on the
the client-side uh brand marketers that
want to learn more we're hosting some
you know some kind of Master Class
sessions as well so feel free to hit us
up if you're interested in joining some
of those
um so excited about everything that's in
store Avery and thank you so much
take care everybody
all right and thanks to all of you for
joining today we're going to have our
next episode uh on April 12th where
we'll be talking about something that we
call social pack which is social
platforms and culture and how Brands can
become more relevant so please don't
forget to register you can sign up at
mftn that's for marketing for the now
mftn.vaynerx.com and we will see you
there